negative thoughts are like roaches they
ruin everything they are absolutely
despicable and if you don't pay
attention to them they reproduce
exponentially they should be
extinguished off the face of the Earth
but how do you take care of this thought
infestation if you will if first of all
you're not even aware that you have this
problem this is where journaling comes
in as the new year begins many of us
will resolve to adopt new positive
habits to improve or change our lives
and besides reading and waking up early
I can't think of a more life-changing
habit for me than having started to
journal but in the past when I had
thought about journaling I always
pictured the typical my dear diary style
entries and that was just not for me so
today I'm going to share with you 10
different ways that you can use a
journal to actually improve your life so
that you can become a more productive
and positive individual and the best
part is that most of these will take
under five minutes making this the
perfect Habit to start for the new year
first up is morning Pages this is
inspired by the author Julia Cameron and
her book the artist's way morning page
just has been my go-to for years now you
basically take out a pen and paper and I
did say pen because the point is not for
you to obsess over your pristine
handwriting and make sure that you write
everything correctly and have the
perfect grammar it is simply a place
where you can just let go of all of the
random thoughts that you have and all of
the mental clutter that's fogging up
your creative energy as the name
suggests this is done in the morning it
is stream of Consciousness writing
basically you're writing anything and
everything that comes to your mind what
this does is it allows you to just let
go of these things so that you can start
your day with a blank slate and as the
days go by what this also allows you to
do is to be able to see kind of patterns
in your writing maybe you keep writing
down that you should call a particular
friend that might be a hint that you
should do that or maybe you keep writing
down something that had hurt you in the
past maybe that's something you should
address or maybe you keep having the
idea that you should start a particular
project that might be a hint that you
should head in that direction I like to
think of morning Pages like a mental
shower but for your brain so that you
can give your day your best number two
is to write 10 Ideas Daily I love this
one this has definitely been a game
changer for me this is inspired by the
best-selling author James altiter what I
did is I basically got myself a small
Journal where every single day I would
force myself to write 10 Ideas Daily
James alticher describes ideas as planes
flying by and by writing them down
you're giving those ideas a place to
land whether you realize it or not you
get several ideas throughout the day but
we just get so caught up in the busy to
Do's of life that we sometimes don't
even realize this and by writing them
down you're not only making them more
likely that they will actually happen
but you're kind of stretching your
creative muscle if you will whether they
might be life-changing ones or simple
ones like changing the light bulb in the
bathroom for example and the more ideas
that you write down the more creative
you become you are training yourself to
become an individual who sees
opportunities and sees possibilities if
you write down 10 Ideas Daily that's
3650 ideas in a year at least a few of
these have got to be good ones and one
of these could change your life number
three is affirmations positive
visualization and prayer I was a
teenager in early college and I remember
hearing about affirmations and rolling
my eyes and scoffing
like that'll do anything I am personally
a person who believes in the power of
prayer and that the words that you say
and think actually have a direct impact
on your life when you say something like
I'm so stupid or I'm so clumsy your
brain is creating neural connections
that further affirm this belief there
are numerous studies out there that show
that positive visualization can actually
improve physical outcomes because your
brain doesn't know the difference
between imagination and reality think
back to a time when you had thought
about something sad and you started to
actually feel the emotions and made
yourself cry just because of thinking
about that situation that event wasn't
actually happening but your brain didn't
know the difference well thankfully the
same is true for the opposite you can
jot down in a journal visualize what
success actually looks like for you what
it will feel like to accomplish that
goal that you have or how you will
change your life in the future be
detailed about these things where will
you live what will your friends be like
what your future experiences will look
like what your future life will look
like or you can also pretend to be your
older wiser self that's giving you
encouragement and giving you motivation
you can also choose to write hopeful
prayers for things that you would like
to see change in your life whichever
route you decide to take no doubt this
journaling style can be a game changer
for sure because it trains your brain to
be positive and to be kinder to yourself
as well number four is unsent angry
letters oh my goodness this is such a
powerful one I love love love this
journaling style as a child I remember
frequently waking up in the middle of
the night to my parents yelling at each
other and my dad's slamming on the table
right across the trailer wall of my
bedroom growing up in a broken marriage
I did not learn the best communication
skills and though I'm blessed to say
I've been happily married for six years
now I definitely needed to work on my
communication skills because my instinct
was definitely fight or flight and most
of the times I would just kind of hold
things in and let them bother me let
them bother me and then finally explode
but when I heard about unsent angry
letters this was life-changing it
definitely transformed the way that I
communicated not only with my husband
but other people as well what I do with
this is that when I'm upset with
somebody not even just angry but I'm
let's say I'm hurt and I don't know the
particular reason before I go speak to
that individual I write them a letter
that is not meant to be ever sent or
ever be seen you can shred it or burn it
or do whatever you want with it after
it's written the point is to allow
yourself to express the emotion without
covering up any colorful language so
that you can allow yourself to just
release it kind of like a wave that's
rising in the ocean and then allowing it
to fall because when we suppress our
emotions those things eventually will
cause turmoil inside us if we don't just
release it not only that but this allows
you a chance to actually figure out why
this particular thing hurts you and a
way that you can actually speak to this
individual calmly after having gone
through all of these emotions but I
highly recommend this especially for
couples as well because all too often
poor communication leads to separation
number five is simple little quick but
powerful and it is small wins every
night before you go to bed instead of
thinking about all the things that you
should have done all the things that you
procrastinated on all the things that
went wrong that day think about those
small wins this can be something so
simple like I took the stairs instead of
the elevator I finally replaced that
light bulb in the bathroom or I opened
the door for somebody that was coming by
maybe you didn't get everything done
that day maybe it just seemed like a
horrible terrible day where everything
that could go wrong did go wrong but
when you force yourself to write down at
least five things that went right that
day just five little small wins what you
are doing is you're giving yourself more
compassion and forcing yourself to think
of the positive this can allow you to
get a better night's rest and allow you
to wake up tomorrow with more positive
energy before we continue if you like
this video and are getting any value
from it make sure you give it a thumbs
up so that not only can you train your
brain for more positive energy but you
can also train the YouTube algorithm to
give you more positive videos like these
number six is prompted writing I used to
be very critical of this type of writing
because I always envisioned my high
school writing assignments where I had
to write about a particular topic and it
just felt like work but prompted writing
can actually be very fun if you have the
right topics there are many prompted
journals out there but you can also
choose questions of your own the
questions should bring about positive
thoughts and give you a sense of
direction such as what does my dream
life look like what is my ideal self
like what advice would future me have
for myself today or what are some ways
that I could practice more self-care no
doubt prompted writing can fit those of
you who like a more creative style of
writing number seven is the bullet
Journal no list of journaling methods
would be complete without mentioning the
ever so popular bullet Journal bullet
journaling is aimed for personal
organization it's a place where you can
organize and visualize your schedule
your reminders ideas or other to-do's in
a way that suits your creative style it
is not prompted it doesn't have lines on
it it is not clearly defined and that's
the beauty of it you make it work for
you based on what your journaling needs
are you can be as detailed or creative
as you like or as simplified as you like
the bullet Journal is a favorite among
many number eight is words of wisdom or
book quotes through Reading we have the
ability to take knowledge that people
worked for years to obtain and have it
condensed in one book if you haven't
started a reading habit already I highly
recommend you check out my video how to
start a reading habit I'll link that
video down below but if you do currently
read or listen to audiobooks or even
podcasts for that matter a great way to
extract even more information from it is
to have the designated spot where you
can write down key takeaways quotes or
just things that stood out to you this
gives you the ability to not only just
read or even just hear the information
mindlessly but gives you a chance to
actually process and digest the
information and who knows maybe you'll
get some insights of your own number
nine is a gratitude Journal you can
choose to do this either in the morning
or at night or even both this is just
having an area where you can write down
things that you're grateful for and
especially if you're doing this in the
morning you're just kind of starting
your day off right because what you're
doing is instead of waking up thinking
about all the things that you have to do
or all the things that worry or stress
you you're thinking about all the things
that you are grateful for all of the
things that are going right and when you
do this at night is just as powerful
because now you're not keeping yourself
up at night thinking about all those
negative things you're thinking about
the positives allowing you to get a full
nice and peaceful rest number 10 is
ironically the dear diary entry even
though this is not my particular writing
style it may be helpful for those of you
who just want a way to just Express what
you feel what you think or just things
that happen throughout the day it can
definitely be a very healing and
insightful type of writing but I do want
to caution as well that if you are going
through something difficult that it's
always a good idea to find somebody that
you can go to that maybe can guide you
in a positive direction or seek a
counselor so that you're not just kind
of keeping things to yourself if you are
going through something major so these
are the 10 different ways that you can
start a journaling Habit to improve your
life let me know in the comments below
which one would you be starting if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so you won't miss when
I post a new video I thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one bye for now